Thank you to all of
you for coming along.
Now as Tom mentioned, I'm
researcher at the London School
of Hygiene and
Tropical Medicine where
I specialise in mathematical
models of infectious disease.
So on the face of it, my job
couldn't be further really
from the world of
casinos and playing
cards and plastic chips.
But really science
and gambling have
incredibly intertwined
relationship,
a really longstanding history.
And that's what I want to
talk about this evening.
And seeing as I'm
talking about gambling,
I thought I would start with an
example of how not to gamble.
So this is a story--
story from a few years ago.
And as you can probably
notice, there's
two large flaws with
this lady's strategy.
The first is it's
completely illegal.
And the second is it
clearly doesn't work.
And the reason I
wanted to show you
this is I think when
we talk about people
taming chance and
beating the system,
typically these are two themes
that crop up quite a lot.
You either have them doing
something a bit dodgy.
Or you have them
presenting a system
which clearly isn't going to
do something very successful.
And what I want
to do this evening
is take a look at
a third approach.
Take a look at some of the
ways in which mathematicians
or scientists have
taken on games of chance
and used their techniques to
get an edge over the house.
I also want to look at
how the ideas have flowed
the other way, how actually
games and gambling have
inspired many
ideas which are now
fundamental to modern
maths and science.
And really lotteries, I
think, are a good place
to start, because for me, it
was a story about lotteries
that first got me interested
in the mathematics of betting.
As I'm sure any of you
who've played the lottery
or have thought about
playing lottery will know
it's incredibly
difficult to win.
But actually, even
the way we measure
how difficult it is to win is
a fairly recent development.
Although maths is-- has
been around for millennia.
The idea of how
we quantify luck,
how we quantify random events,
is a relatively recent one.
It was one that was developed
in the 16th century.
And it was actually
in Veneto, Italy.
There was a Italian
called Gerolamo Cardano.
He was a physician.
As a doctor, he was the first to
describe the clinical symptoms
of typhoid.
He was also a gambler.
And as a gambler, he was the
first to describe such games
mathematically.
And he actually outlined
what's known as a sample space.
So this is the--
all of the combinations of
events that could occur.
And obviously, if you're only
interested in one of those,
that gives you a sense of
how difficult it is to win.
Now for the UK National
Lottery as it stands,
you have to pick six numbers
from a possible set of 59.
So this results in just over 45
million possible combinations
of you-- of numbers you could
pick if you bought a card.
Clearly this makes
life very difficult
for you to win the jackpot.
But there is a way that
you can guarantee you will
win the lottery this weekend.
And that is quite simply to
buy up every single combination
of numbers.
Now that might sound
a little bit absurd.
But let's just run
with it for a moment.
As I said, there's 45
million combinations
of tickets for the UK lottery.
So if you were to buy up every
single possible combination
and line them up end-to-end,
it would actually
stretch from London to Dubai.
What's more, each
ticket cost 2 pounds.
So if you really want to win
the jackpot this weekend,
it's going to cost about 90
million pounds to achieve.
Clearly that's not
a feasible strategy.
But not all lotteries
are the same.
In the 1990s, for example,
the Irish National Lottery
had a much smaller
sample space--
a much smaller possible
combination of numbers
that could come up.
In fact, there were about
1.94 million combinations.
Each ticket costs 50p.
So as a result, it would cost
you less than a million pounds
to buy up every
single combination.
And actually a syndicate
headed up by an accountant
got thinking about this.
And clearly most weeks, this
is a pretty poor investment,
because the jackpot would be
maybe a few hundred thousand.
And if you're spending
almost a million
to win a few hundred
thousand, doesn't
take much to spot that's
a pretty bad investment.
But if a rollover
were to come around,
maybe this could be plausible.
And actually rather
than stretching it
to Dubai, if you lined
up all of these tickets
and the combinations
end-to-end, it
would actually stretch
from London to Plymouth.
So you've got something
that's a bit more doable.
And what they started to do is
collect together these tickets
and fill each one out by
hand to get every single one
of these combinations.
And then they waited.
They waited for about six
months until the May Bank
Holiday in 1992 when the
rollover hit 2.2 million.
And they put their
plan into action.
They took all these
tickets they'd
filled out, started taking them
to shops, and buying them up.
And in many cases this
raised some attention.
So shops that would usually
sale maybe a thousand tickets
in a week were suddenly
selling 15,000.
The Lottery perhaps expectantly,
frowned upon this a little bit
and tried to stop them.
And as a result, when the
lottery draw came around,
they'd only bought 80% of
the possible combinations
of tickets.
So there's still an element
of luck as to whether they'd
win the jackpot.
Fortunately for them,
that jackpot's winning set
of numbers was within
the combinations
that they bought up.
So they won that week.
Unfortunately, there were
two other winners that week.
So they had to
split the jackpot.
But when you added up all
those lower tier prizes
that they match five numbers,
four numbers as well,
they walked away with a
profit of 300,000 pounds.
Now for me, years ago
when I heard the story,
that was just a
fantastic illustration
of how you can take a pretty
simple mathematical insight,
a good dose of
audacity and hard work,
and convert it into
something that's profitable.
And this isn't the only
instance that people have
targeted these kind of games.
For the UK lottery,
the draw is random.
So really the only way
you can guarantee a win
is to use this brute force
approach by simply buying up
all of the combinations.
But not all lotteries
are the same.
Take scratchcards, for example.
On the face of it, scratchcards
are completely random.
If you think about it, they
can't be completely random.
Because if you're
producing scratchcards,
and you just randomly
generate which
cards are going to
be winners, there's
a chance that by
sheer chance you will
produce too many winning cards.
If you're a company
making scratchcards,
you want some way of
controlling and limiting
which prizes go out.
As statisticians will call it,
you need controlled randomness.
You want the prizes to be fairly
uniformly, evenly distributed
amongst the occasions.
But you don't want
the generation
to be completely random.
And actually in
2003, a statistician
called Mohan Srivastava was
thinking about scratchcards.
He'd been given some
as a joke present
and was wondering on this
idea of controlled randomness.
And he realised there must
be some way for the lottery
to identify which cards
were winners without having
to scratch them off.
On each card there were
a series of digits.
And some of these would
appear two times, three times.
But some numbers and symbols
only appeared once on the card.
And actually if these unique
numbers appeared in a row,
that card was always a winner.
And he went and
bought more cards
and tested out his strategy.
And every single time, the cards
that had these numbers in a row
were guaranteed winners.
Now what would you
do in this situation?
You've essentially
cracked scratchcards.
You've got a system
which can identify
the winning ones and
the not winning ones
just by looking at them.
Would you go out and buy tonnes?
What would you do?
Well, think back to that slide
that I showed you at the start.
Winning scratchcards
are remarkably rare.
And actually what Mohan
did, rather than just
going on a huge
scratchcard buying spree,
was work out how long it would
take him to buy up enough cards
and guarantee himself a winner.
And he was a statistician
working on geological problems
earning pretty decent money.
And he realised that actually,
although he had a winning
lottery strategy, it was
better off just to stick in his
existing job.
So what he did was he
rang up the lottery
and told them that
there was a hidden code
on their scratchcards,
and he had deciphered it,
and he knew how to win.
The lottery, of course,
didn't take him seriously.
So what he did was actually
collected the scratchcards.
And he identified some winning
ones, some losing ones,
divided them into two
piles and posted them
by courier to lottery.
That evening he got a phone
call from lottery saying,
we need to have a chat.
And really the story
is representative
of a lot of areas of gambling.
Often it's not
professional gamblers
who come up with
these strategies that
beat the system.
And often people
who beat the system,
don't become
professional gamblers.
For a lot of these
people, gambling
is almost a
playground for ideas.
It's a way of testing out
problem solving and skills that
actually would apply to
many other industries.
People who have
tried these problems
are moving into academia,
into finance, into business.
And as I mentioned with Cardano,
this isn't a new phenomenon.
Really throughout history,
many of the great thinkers
and mathematicians
have used gambling
as a way of refining
their ideas.
In around 1900, a
French mathematician
called Henri Poincare was
particularly interested
in gambling.
Now Poincare was one of the--
what's know as the
last universalists.
As a mathematician, he
was one of the last people
to specialise in almost
every area of the subject
as existed at the time.
It hadn't expanded
to the point where
it was as large as it is today.
And one of the things
he was interested in
was predictability.
And to him, unexpected
events, unexpected outcomes
were the result of ignorance.
He thought if something
is unexpected,
it's because we're
ignorant of the causes.
And he classed these
problems by what he called
the three levels of ignorance.
The top level was
a situation where
we know what the rules are,
we have the information,
we just have to do some
basic calculations.
So if you've got, say,
a school physics exam,
you know what the
physical laws are.
You're given the information.
So in theory, you should be
able to get the right answer.
If your answer is
surprising, then you've
done something wrong
in the working.
But it's not a kind of
difficult level of ignorance
to escape, in theory.
The second level of ignorance
according to Poincare
was one where you know
what the rules are,
but you lack the information
necessary to carry out
the calculations accurately.
And he used roulette
as an example.
So a roulette table, you start
a ball spinning round and round.
And he observed a very small
change in the initial speed
of the ball could have a
very dramatic effect on where
it ends up, because
it's going to be
circling this table over time.
And nowadays
mathematicians refer
to this as sensitive dependence
on initial conditions.
And popularly it's known
as the butterfly effect.
There's a talk in the '70s
where a physicist pointed out
that a butterfly flapping
its wings in Brazil
could cause or perhaps
prevent a tornado in Texas.
These very small changes,
which Poincare first observed,
could have a very
large effect later on.
And then we'll say that
the results is random.
It's down to chance.
But really, it's a
problem of information.
Then comes the third
degree of ignorance.
And this is where we
don't know the rules.
Or perhaps they're
so complex, we'll
never be able to untangle them.
And in this situation,
all we can do is watch.
Watch over time and try
and gain some understanding
of what we're observing.
And it's really this
level of ignorance
when gamblers started targeting
roulette that they focused on.
They didn't try and untangle
all of these physical laws.
They just said, well, let's
just watch a load of roulette
spins at a table and
see if there's a bias.
See if there's something odd
going on with this table.
But this raises the
question of what
do we actually mean by odd.
What do we mean by biassed?
And while Poincare was thinking
about roulette in France,
on the other side
of the channel,
a mathematician called
Karl Pearson was also
thinking about roulette.
And Pearson was fascinated
by random events.
As he said, we can't have any
true sense of what nature does.
We can only observe and
try and make inferences
on those observations.
And he's really keen to
collect random data to test out
these kind of ideas.
On one occasion he spent his
summer holiday flipping a coin
25,000 times to generate
a data set to analyse.
And he was also
interested in roulette.
Now fortunately for
him at the time,
the Le Monaco
newspaper would publish
the results of all
the roulette spins
in the casinos at Monte Carlo.
Now for Pearson this is
a fantastic data set.
He wants to test out his
ideas about randomness.
You've got all these
previous roulette
spins to test it out on.
And he started looking at ways
to understand whether they
were random or not.
And a roulette table,
of course, you've
got these black and red numbers.
And then you've got zero.
If you take out
the zero, over time
you'd expect the proportion
of black and red to be even.
You'd expect it to
be 50/50 over time.
And when Pearson
looked at the data,
he found that red came
up 50.15% of the time.
This was over
about 16,000 spins.
So according to his calculation,
this wasn't that implausible,
that actually that
kind of deviation
from the expected value
is reasonable given
the kind of data set he had.
But then he continued.
And he looked, for instance,
at how often pairs of numbers
appear.
Now if you've got a random
process at roulette table,
sometimes you'd expect there to
be a string of the same colour
appearing purely by chance.
You might get a few reds
coming up-- a few blacks.
But what Pearson found was that
the number switched too often,
that actually you didn't get
these strings of the same
colour appearing as often
as you might expect.
They were switching over.
And to him this was
pretty definitive evidence
that the tables were corrupt,
that they were biassed.
And as he puts it, if I had
been observing these tables
since the start of
geological time on Earth,
I would not have expected to
see a result that extreme.
And he actually suggested that
they close down the casinos
and donate the
proceeds to science.
As it happened there was
something a little bit more
down to earth going on.
It turned out that those
journalists from Le Monaco,
rather than sitting
by the tables
and recording the
numbers, instead
had been sitting in the
bar and making them up.
But this idea-- think
back to how he phrased it.
It was the probability
of observing
an event as extreme as
the one I've observed.
This was the first
forays into what's
known as hypothesis testing.
Nowadays, whether we
work in clinical trials
or on particle
physics experiments,
we use the principles that
Pearson honed on these roulette
tables and coin
tosses to understand
whether we have enough
evidence to reject or accept
a certain hypothesis.
So in this case
his hypotheses was
that the tables were random.
And he had enough evidence to
say that this wasn't the case.
And actually gamblers
have also used these ideas
throughout Victorian times.
And moving into late
1940s, for example,
two medical students used
these kind of methods to go
and unlike the lazy
journalists, they
actually watched the tables this
time, collected all the data
and found that
there were biases.
These tables bore
down over time.
And certain numbers
or areas would
appear more often than not.
And actually they
went around Nevada
and gambolled at
all these tables.
And the exact figure
was never known.
But they did buy a
yacht and sell around
the Caribbean for a year-- so
a pretty successful strategy.
The problem for
gamblers, though,
is casinos cottoned on
to what they were doing.
And they would make sure the
tables were incredibly well
maintained and you didn't
have these biases occurring.
But in the '60s and '70s, some
physics students realised that
this actually leaves you in
the second level of ignorance.
Because if you've got a very
pristine, well-maintained
roulette table, it's not
a statistics problem.
It's a physics one.
As one of them said,
it's kind of like having
a planet orbiting a point.
You got this ball going around.
In the '70s, a group of students
at University of California,
Santa Cruz actually started
doing these calculations.
And they looked
at roulette spin.
And they said,
well, to start off
with, the croupier
will spin the ball.
And it would go around
the edge of the track
around the rim of the table.
And often it would go
around a couple of times
before the croupier
calls no more bets.
In other words,
you have a window
in which you can collect
information on what the ball is
doing and act on it.
You can place bets
during this period.
Over time it would drop
down onto the track.
And this will spin
freely and eventually hit
one of these deflectors and
land in one of the pockets.
And what's it-- they actually
did testing out their strategy
on different tables in their lab
was realised that if you could
calibrate your models-- if you
could write down the equations
for the physical system-- you
got the ball going around.
It's slowing down
and then drops down.
If you write down
these equations that
calibrate into a
specific table, then
in that initial bit
of time, you could
collect enough information
to improve your prediction
about where the ball would land.
You'd never get exactly.
But you didn't need to.
You just need to get some idea
of which region of the table
is going to land in, enough to
get an edge over the casino.
It's all well and
good, of course,
doing that in a classroom and
working for all occasions--
all the equations.
But in a casino, you need
to do it in real time.
You need to do that
on the casino floor
as the ball is spinning.
So what these teams
actually did was come up
with hidden computers to do
these calculations in person.
Now wearable technology
is, of course,
all around us these days.
But the first wearable computer
was designed for this purpose
as it happens.
And because it was
a new technology,
there were, of course,
some drawbacks for this.
They'd often give themselves
electric shocks for example.
And as well as this--
as I mentioned,
things are very sensitive
to initial conditions.
So if the weather
changed, they would
need to recalibrate
to the roulette table.
On one occasion they
were actually losing
a fair bit of money and
couldn't quite work out why.
Until they realised there's an
overweight tourist further down
leaning on the table
and screwing up all
of their predictions.
So really these kind of methods
were somewhat imperfect.
In theory they worked very well.
But these kind of stories
have been a bit sporadic.
But it wasn't just
roulette during this period
that gamblers started targeting.
They also started
targeting other games.
And actually one of the
most successful gamblers
in the world is a man by
the name of Bill Benter.
And when he was a student in the
'70s, he came across this sign
in an Atlantic City casino.
Now to him this sign
meant one thing.
Card counting clearly works.
And the whole idea of
card counting-- so if you
have games like blackjack.
You're trying to get to
a certain total playing
the dealer.
And in blackjack, you try and
get near to 21 but not go over.
So you've got to draw cards and
try and get near this total.
On the face of it,
this is a random game.
The draw is completely
random what will come out.
But of course, it's not
for a deck of cards.
Because if certain cards
have already come out,
they can't reappear until
you shuffle the deck.
So if you can
collect information
on what's already appeared,
this can potentially give you
an edge over the casino.
It can give you an
advantage against them.
Now again, casinos started
realising what players were
doing, that they were
tracking what was in the deck.
So they started using
more decks of cards.
Rather than one, they
would use a whole pile.
And this made it much
harder to card count.
Because if there's multiple
of the same card in the deck,
it's much more difficult to
keep track of what's come out
and what hasn't.
But the casinos
were inadvertently
handing the gamblers a
very significant advantage,
because at the time,
casinos typically
used what's know as
a dovetail shuffle.
So this is probably
familiar to you.
You split the deck in two.
You riffle the cards together.
Now a dovetail shuffle,
if you do it once,
preserves an enormous amount
of information about the cards.
So just to give you
an example, let's say
we have a six pack of cards
in order from ace to king.
If we do a dovetail
shuffle, we split them.
I've coloured them just
to make life a bit easier.
And then we riffle
them together.
Now they might not fall
exactly interwoven.
But you can see here in
two different colours,
you've got two quite clear
what's known as rising
sequences of numbers.
So cards have been shuffled.
But actually, if you know where
they started at each point
as you go from left to right,
you know there's only one
of two cards that
could be appearing.
And actually there's a
number of magic tricks
that rely on this fact.
So if you get a deck of cards
and move one and then riffle
shuffle, you can spot with--
the moved card-- because
it won't fit into one
of these rising sequences.
As mathematicians have shown
that for this kind of shuffle,
you need to shuffle the deck at
least half a dozen or so times
to get something that's
as good as random.
And in casinos in that
period, people were actually
only shuffling them once.
So really if you can
track what's happened,
you've got a huge
amount of information
about what's going on.
And in many cases, they would
actually sneak in pieces.
And again, another opportunity
at confusing casinos--
to track the cards that
have come previously.
And whereas before card counters
would measure what's come
and then get a custom
approximation of what's
left, now they'd actually
at each point in time
know that there's only one of
two cards that could appear.
So this is a terrific
advantage that they had.
But this poses a challenge,
because how do you capitalise
on that?
At each point in
time, let's say,
there's a card
that's advantageous
and less beneficial.
How do you make that
decision about how much
to risk in that situation?
And what I want to do is just
start with a simple example.
Let's suppose we
have a coin toss.
And I'm going to offer
you a biassed bet here.
So I'm going to offer you
two to one odds on tails.
So in other words, you
name an amount of money.
If it comes up heads, you
pay me that amount of money.
If it comes up tails,
then I will pay you
double the amount you named.
So clearly that's a pretty
stupid bet on my part.
I'm giving you an advantage.
But how much would you
be willing to risk?
After all, it is a coin
toss, and you would still
have a chance of losing money.
Could I just get a
quick show of hands?
Who here would be willing to
risk one pound on that bet?
Show of hands--
OK, so I think most of you.
Keep your hand out if you be
willing to risk 10 pounds.
OK, how about 100 pounds?
OK, and 500?
How many times do
you get to play?
Once.
OK, so there's a
few people left.
I'm not sure if they're
playing with monopoly money.
But OK, so if you
put your hands down.
That wasn't legally
binding, anyway.
But I waned to give you
a chance to kind of get
a feeling of measuring risk.
How much are you willing
to risk in that situation?
And I don't know if you can
see, but actually the hands
kind of went down a lot between
10 and a hundred pounds.
But this is quite an important
question for gamblers.
And actually in the
'50s, a physicist
called John Kelly
started thinking
about this idea of biassed bets.
Suppose you have
inside information.
And you have some edge over
a book maker or casino.
How do you exploit that?
In this situation for you,
although I gave all of you
the exact same bets--
mathematically it's the same
offer--
your perception of the value
of that was very different.
Some of you valued it at a
pound, some at 10, some at 500.
What's the optimal
thing to do there?
There's actually this concept
known as utility in economics.
It's the value of
something changes
depending on how much money is
in your wallet, for example,
and how much you're
willing to lose.
And what Kelly did is he
looked at these two contrasting
aims you have, if you want to
give a good long-term return.
First you're trying to
make money, because you've
got a biassed bet.
But you're also trying
to avoid going bankrupt.
Essentially you're
still tossing a coin.
There's that chance
you're going to lose.
I don't think anyone here would
have bet their house on this.
Maybe you would have.
You might have an angry family.
But in this case, you want to
somehow exploit it, but also
limit your losses.
And what Kelly did was
come up with this formula.
So I apologise for
my handwriting.
Basically you've got the odds,
which in this case is two.
You got the probability
you'll win-- this Pwin--
minus the probability
you'll lose.
And this is the optimal
fraction of your money
to bet for a given edge over
somebody in a wager situation.
So the bet I just showed you.
The odds were two.
The probability you'll win is a
half, because it's a coin toss.
Probability you'll
lose is also a half.
So if you stick
these numbers in,
you get the following
kind of equation.
A little bit of arithmetic--
you can end up with a quarter.
So in this situation, if you
want to maximise your long-term
growth of money, it's optimal
to risk about a quarter
of your income.
Just have a think back
to when you were raising
hands, whether that
was the course of--
were you taking
advantage or not?
Now some of you might think,
OK, that's all well and good.
You showed me a formula.
Let's test it out.
Now I could have, of course,
adopt the Karl Pearson approach
and spend the next half an
hour or so tossing coins
to convince you.
That's a bit boring.
So what I thought I'd
do instead is show you
some simulations
of if we adopted
different strategies, what
kind of outcomes we would get.
So here along the
vertical is your bankroll.
I'm going to assume that you
start with a hundred pounds.
And along the bottom
is the coin flips.
So we're going to
play this bet again,
and again, and
again, and see what
you'd end up with over time.
Now you might have thought a
quarter of my money, that's
not taking risks.
So I want to go big.
You might say, well, I want
to bet 80% of my money.
And in this case, if we just
do one random simulation, what
might happen is you'll
get a couple of big wins
at the start.
You're approaching
a thousand pounds.
Lose a load of money--
win a load of money.
It's exciting.
And then lose all your
money and go bankrupt--
Less exciting.
If you adopt this
optimal Kelly strategy
and bet 25%, what will happen
is it will take longer.
You'll grow a bit
slow over time.
But you won't go bankrupt.
And actually in
the long term, you
will get something
that takes off.
You might say actually, that's
still a bit too much for me.
I'm going to bet
10% of my income
on each one of these wages.
And in this case, if
you do it randomly,
it'll take a long time to grow.
So you won't go bankrupt.
But it will take much more
time to bet your money.
And you notice this
kind of increases quite
steeply at the end.
And that's because you're
reinvesting your money.
It's this kind of compound
interest effect over time.
Again, this is just
one simulation.
It's a coin toss.
It's a bit of randomness.
So what we could do is
simulate it, say, 10 times.
Instead of this
one instance here,
do each one of
these 10 times over.
And in the case
where you bet 80%,
you're going to end up
with something which
nine of these you go
bankrupt, one of them
you do make a bit of money.
But in most of these cases,
you'll run out of your income
pretty quickly.
If you bet 25%,
this optimal amount,
then again, it
grows a bit slower.
But you don't go
bankrupt at any point.
And you will eventually
grow your income.
And then again, this 10% is
just a much slower growth.
So it takes much, much
more time to build this up
over the series of bets.
And this is the
strategy that people
use playing blackjack--
playing a lot these games
to manage their bankroll.
And actually the concept of
utility and money management
is obviously
important in finance.
But it underpins the
entire insurance industry,
because whether we
insure something or not
depends on how we
value it, whether we're
willing to risk the fact that
we could lose it and cost us out
of a lot of money, or whether
we take those small premiums.
That would depend on
the value of the item.
But implementing this strategy,
of course, for card counters
can still be a problem.
As one card counter I talked
to said, learning to card count
is easy.
Learning to get away with
it is very difficult.
And many of these people
who were successful,
people like Bill Benter soon
became pretty well known
in the world of
casinos and found
themselves banned from all
the way around the world.
So they turned their
attention to a bigger game,
a much larger place to wager.
Now, this is Happy Valley
Racecourse in Hong Kong.
If you've ever been
Wednesday night,
this is kind of where
all the action is.
On a typical race day, about
$150 million are wagered.
Gambling is an enormous part
of what's going on here.
One of the appeals for this for
gamblers is a fairly small--
well, firstly it's-- they're
pretty convinced it's an honest
operation.
And it's a small pool of
horses, about a thousand
horses that run again,
and again, and again.
So you can generate lots
of data to look at and try
and interpret which horse
might have a good chance.
But to do that, of
course, you need
some way of converting data
into a measure of performance.
Which horse is the best?
Which horse is going to win?
And to use this, teams turned
to an idea that was first
conjured up by this man.
This is Francis Galton, a
Victorian scientist and cousin
actually of Charles Darwin.
And as you can see, they shared
some passions particularly
for cravats and short sideburns.
But there were some differences.
Darwin actually was meticulous
in shaping his research.
So even the theory
of evolution, you
can see many of his
fingerprints over this.
Now Galton liked to think of
himself more as an explorer.
He would dabble in anthropology,
and psychology, and biology,
and economics, and
then start it off a bit
and then leave it and wander
off to something else.
And one of the things he was
interested in was inheritance.
And he actually
on some occasions
would send his friends seeds and
get them to grow them for him.
It's kind of an early
crowdsourcing approach--
and get them to report back.
And one of the things he'd
notice is that if you grew
a season and had the
subsequent generation,
if those were for
instance taller,
you wouldn't expect the next
generation to be taller,
and taller, and taller-- that
over time you'd get a feature
which he referred to as
regression to mediocrity--
that over time these
kind of features
would somehow converge.
And the influence of
the older lineages
might kind of smooth
over variation.
He wanted to understand this in
a slightly more rigorous way.
And it was actually
a horse trainer
who presented him
with a figure, which
allowed him to frame this idea.
And it was the following.
It was a diagram.
It was a square
which represented
the characteristics of a horse.
And this trainer had
proposed that about half
of the characteristics
are explained
by the mother and the father.
So you have a couple
of squares for those.
And then of the remaining
characteristics,
maybe a quarter is explained
by the four grandparents.
And then another
chunk is explained
by the great
grandparents and so on.
And this idea was
one of the founders
of what's known as regression
theory in statistics.
It's the idea that we can
take a number of factors
and work out how it
influences the characteristics
of a certain object or system.
And we could have a similar
approach in horse racing.
We could say, well,
let's just suppose
this box is the
performance of the horse.
And we have lots of
different bits of past data.
And we could say, well, maybe
each one of these bits of data
explains some amount of
the horse's performance.
Of course, this is a bit
simplistic, really, isn't it.
Because just like with the
characteristics of inheritance
where, for instance,
some of the variation
is explained by the
parents that are also
going to be shared
with the grandparents,
the characteristics of
a horse-- these features
are going to overlap.
Some of these will
explain multiple aspects.
So these kind of
things are going
to be a bit more jumbled up.
And what's more, we might
not be able to explain
all of the horse's performance.
There might be some chunk
which we still can't explain.
And really the aim from a
statistical point of view is
to try and minimise
this unknown quantity.
And there's actually-- in the
'80s, Bill Benter visiting
a library in Nevada
came across a paper
by two researchers called Ruth
Bolton and Randall Chapman.
They work in marketing.
They still do actually.
And they had essentially
outlined this method
for horse races, this
approach of converting data
into some kind of
measure of performance
that you could use
to make predictions.
And as Bill said,
it was the idea
that sowed a multibillion
pound industry-- an incredibly
important piece of research.
And actually for Ruth
Bolton, it was the only paper
she wrote about horse racing.
It's during her PhD.
And it was really kind
of a side project.
But this had a huge
impact on this industry.
And on doing the analysis of
those early syndicates in Hong
Kong, certain things would
come out as more important.
For example, in one of their
early bits of research,
the number of races
a horse had run
would tell you a lot about
how it's going to do.
And it's tempting to come
up with a story for that.
We say, well, if
it's run more races,
then it's going to
be more experienced.
And then that's going
to give it a better
performance in the next race.
But they actually
avoid doing that,
because really they
know it's a jumble,
that all of these things are
going to overlap and explain
one thing.
And it's not clear that just
because something is important,
it has a direct explanation.
This quite common
problem in statistics
is known as this idea that
correlation doesn't always
mean causation.
Just to give an example,
here we have along the bottom
is the wine spend per year
at the Cambridge colleges.
On the vertical is
the exam results.
So as you--
[LAUGHTER]
As you can see, there's a
pretty strong correlation
between colleges that spend more
on wine have better results.
And this isn't the only
thing that's happened.
Actually it turns
out that countries
that have a higher per
capita spend on chocolate
typically win more Nobel Prizes.
As lovely as it would be that
eating chocolate would make you
a Nobel Prize winner
and drinking wine
would make you better at
exams, there's clearly
something else going on.
There's some underlying
feature which
explains all of these things.
And really these
syndicates therefore
don't try and untangle it.
And actually one of
the remarkable things
is they have no desire
to be pundits and experts
on this kind of field.
For them the question is
what horse is going to win,
not why is that
horse going to win.
So it's almost this going
back to the idea of ignorance.
They're embracing
their ignorance.
And they're saying,
I don't really
mind that I can't explain
exactly how it's going.
I just want a
method that is going
to give me good predictions.
Now starting off by measuring
performance is one good thing.
But actually when you have
multiple horses racing,
you can get some slightly
unexpected results occurring.
So just an example,
a very simple one,
let's suppose we
have two horses.
We have one which half
the time does well,
half the time does badly.
On the day, you don't know
which it's going to be.
And you have the
second horse which
is a bastion of reliability.
Every single race, exactly
the same performance.
Now on average over
lots and lots of races,
they've got the same
kind of performance,
because the top one on
average that will cancel out.
And in a race, it will
be essentially a 50-50,
because it completely
depends in a race
whether the top
horse number one is
having a good day or a bad day.
So these two horses
race against each other.
It's basically a coin toss.
It's a 50/50 chance, because
if the top horse is having
a good day, he's going to win.
If he's having a bad
day, he's going to lose.
That's kind of intuitive.
But if you add a third
horse into the mix,
something a bit strange happens.
So let's suppose we
have a third horse here,
which some days
performed slightly
better than the middle
horse, some days performed
slightly worse.
So again on average,
all these horses
have the same performance.
Now by the same kind of logic,
the top horse here again
has a 50% chance of winning,
because half the time he
will come out front and half
the time he'll come out last.
So he still has a 50%
chance of winning.
Of the two horses that remain,
if the top horse doesn't win,
we can apply the same logic.
Of these two horses
on the bottom,
if the horse number
three has a good day,
he's going to come out on top.
And if he has a bad
day, he's going to lose.
So if the top horse
doesn't win, you
spit the probabilities
between the two horses
remaining, because
you can't decide.
Now just take a look at
what's going on here.
All these horses on average
have identical performance.
But it's the variability
that's different.
And actually the top
horse because it's
most variable in
this kind of race
has a larger chance of winning.
You can actually apply
the same kind of logic
to other situations.
So say we have an election,
which the first past
the post system.
So the person who gets
the most votes wins.
If you have three
people who on average
you'd expect to get the
same amount of votes,
is actually the most
polarising candidate,
the kind of all or nothing one,
which has the best strategy,
because they've got
the largest chance
of winning in this situation.
If you want to push the
example a bit further,
you could look at job interviews
or maybe even dating, if you've
got lots of different suitors.
In this situation,
it makes most sense
to adopt this all or nothing
kind of Marmite strategy,
if the objective is to come out
first against multiple people.
This isn't a problem if
there's only two in the race.
But as soon as you have
multiple competitors,
you get this kind of
weird dynamic coming out.
And really the mathematics
of games and these kind
of features have been
interest to mathematicians
for a long time.
Actually the origins
of game theory,
the origins of mathematics of
games originated with poker.
In the 1920s, a researcher
John Von Neumann--
brilliant mathematician.
He was the youngest
professor in the history
of the University of Berlin--
wasn't so good at poker, though.
On the face of it,
poker is a perfect game
for a mathematician, right?
It's the probability
you get a certain hand--
the probability your opponent
gets a different one.
But von Neumann realised that
there's more to it than that.
He said real life
consists of bluffing--
of little tactics of
deception-- of asking
myself what does the other
man suppose I'm going to do.
And he wanted to study
that kind of feedback
between what you
think, what they think,
and they think you think.
And he looked at very
simplified forms of poker.
And one situation he
looked at was two players.
They each get dealt
a single card.
And then they put some money
in the pot at the start.
And first player has the choice.
So they can either just stick
with their bets, in which case
they just turn over their
cards and compare them.
Or they can raise the stakes.
And then it's up
to the second pair
to decide whether they
meet that bet or not.
So two players, one card,
money in the middle.
What von Neumann found is
that in these kind of games,
you've got almost a tug of war,
because each player is trying
to maximise their gain
while simultaneously trying
to minimise their
opponent's gain.
If you play a game like poker,
anything your opponent wins
comes out of your pocket.
So you're trying to
maximise what you get,
while at the same time trying
to minimise what they get.
Which means that there's this
kind of equilibrium point.
There's a point at which the
two conflicting forces balance.
And this situation--
analysing it for the game.
He found that this situation
in which no player would
benefit by changing their
strategy-- this balance point.
For the first
player, the strategy
was as follows, that if they
got a very high card, then
they should raise the stakes.
Intuitive just makes sense.
If you have a good card,
you might as well bet on it.
If they had a middling card,
it didn't make sense for them
to raise the stakes.
They didn't have a
great chance of winning.
But they still had some chance.
So in other words,
they should just
stick with their existing bet.
But when von Neumann
looked at what
happened when you got
the lowest kind of cards,
he found that it doesn't make
sense to stick with your bet,
because if you turn
over the cards,
you're probably going to lose.
Instead you should
up the stakes.
So in other words,
you should bluff.
And actually up to
this point gamblers
had often-- poker players
had often bluffed in games.
But it was always
seen as a quirk
of human psychology, a
kind of innate trickery
that humans came up with.
But here was von
Neumann showing that it
was a mathematical necessity.
In other words, he
proved that bluffing
is a necessary part of life.
And this idea was
fundamental to game theory,
that you can have these
strategies put together.
In this very simple
version of poker,
though, there's almost a list
of fixed rules we can follow.
So in other words, if
you get high or low card,
you raise the stakes.
If you get a middling card,
you stick with what you've got.
And in any game where you've
got all the information in front
of you-- so other
games for instance--
things like noughts and
crosses, checkers, chess--
all of the games in theory
have a fixed set of rules.
It's known as pure strategy.
So you follow these
exact rules, and you'll
get the optimal result.
So if someone
noughts and crosses,
I think most people can work out
when they are younger that they
realise there's a set of moves.
And if they always
do that, they always
get the results that's
the best possible.
But of course, not all
games are like this.
A good example is
rock, paper, scissors.
So it might be admirably
consistent of you
to always pick the same one.
But if your opponent
spots what you're doing,
they can take advantage of that.
So it's not the kind
of optimal strategy
if you're trying to make
your opponent's decisions as
difficult as possible.
And these kind of games, that's
what you're trying to do.
You're trying to
make your opponent
indifferent to
changing, because you've
got that tug of war going on.
So if they can gain more by
adopting a different strategy,
you haven't got the
optimal approach.
And in rock, paper,
scissors, if you
want to make your opponent's
choices as difficult
as possible, what you can just
simply do is pick randomly.
If you pick completely
random options amongst those,
then in the long
run your opponent
won't be able to make
any money off you.
So this is kind of the
optimal thing to do.
And rock, paper, scissors,
there's three options.
It's not too hard to work
out that picking randomly
will make your opponent's
decisions difficult.
But games like poker
are far more complex.
You have a whole
array of choices
that you can make
through the game.
So it's not something
you can actually
write down with pen and paper.
And fortunately we can
turn to a technique
that one of John von
Neumann's colleagues devised.
And this was a mathematician
called Stanislaw Ulam.
And unlike many
mathematicians, he
wasn't a big fan of working
through loads of equations.
On one occasion he was
working a blackboard trying
to solve a quadratic,
got to the end,
and was just so
frustrated and annoyed,
he went home for the day.
So really kind of
wasn't his thing
to kind of crunch
through all this algebra.
He was once playing
handheld, which
is a version of solitaire.
And he wondered what
the probability would be
if he just laid out the cards.
What's the probability
he'd have a situation where
he could win that game--
the cards would fall
in a favourable way.
He started looking at
calculations and realised it
was just a lot of effort.
So instead he thought,
well, what if I just
lay out the cards a few
times and see what happens.
In other words, what
if I just simulate
this process a few times and get
some sense of how likely it is.
At the time, Ulam and von
Neumann were working on the US
nuclear programme at Los Alamos
working on neutron collisions.
Part of the project
was a hydrogen bomb.
And again these are
random processes
where you couldn't neatly
write down the formulas
and solve them.
And they realised that this
method would be incredibly
powerful for that.
Being a government programme,
they needed a code name for it.
So they called it the
Monte Carlo method,
because Ulam had a heavy
gambling uncle at the time.
And the Monte Carlo
method has become
a fundamental part of science.
I mean in my line of work
where we try and look
at disease outbreaks, you have
something like Ebola or Zika,
that's an incredibly
complex set of interactions.
It's not something you can write
down with pen and paper neatly.
And so we use these
simulation-based approaches
simulating these
random processes
to understand these systems.
It also appears now
as a sports betting
when you're trying to understand
how these very complex team
interactions work.
And it also applies to poker.
Teams have used this kind of
approach for games of poker
where you can't neatly
solve the equations.
You can use a
simulation-based approach
to get the computers to learn.
And actually Allen Turing one
of the fathers of computing,
when he was first thinking about
this idea of machine learning,
said that actually
if you're trying
to build intelligent machine,
it doesn't make sense
to build the adult mind.
You don't want to try and build
the finished product with all
the knowledge that was there.
It makes much more sense
to build the child's mind
and let it learn.
Let it work out how to
play these kinds of games.
And this is what
these poker teams do.
They create these
algorithms that can learn.
And actually the way
in which they learn
is perhaps a bit surprising,
because what they do
is they get these
algorithms over time
to employ what's known
as regret minimisation.
So as they play
these games billions
of times against each other,
at each point when they've
made a decision, they
look back and say,
could I improve that if I'd
done something differently.
So at each point they have an
artificial measure of regret
for each decision they make.
And actually there's
a lot of evidence
from some neurological--
neuroscience studies--
that that ability to have regret
is quite important in learning
games of chance.
There's been studies
of people who
have damage to the bit
of the brain that's
responsible for
regret-- this ability
to look backward
and ask how would
I feel if I'd done
something differently.
And these people
often are perfectly
capable of playing logic games.
If they have to sort cards,
absolutely fine at that.
If there's any element
of risk to the game
and they have to learn how
to play the optimal strategy,
that's something they
really struggle with.
And actually a lot
of economic theories
developed not around
looking back but around
what's known as
expectation maximisation.
So in other words,
you look forward.
And you say, if I did
this, could I make money?
If I did this,
could I make more?
But really from these artificial
intelligence approaches,
it seems that it's
much more powerful
to look back and employ
that power of regret
as you go to look
back on your decisions
as you take these risks.
And in fact these teams have
employed these algorithms
and got these computer bots to
play each other so many times
that last year they announced
that poker is solved.
To be specific, for two-player
poker where the stakes have
a limit, these bots have
played each other so many times
that they've come up
with a strategy which
will not be expected to
lose money in the long run.
So even if you're playing
a perfect opponent,
this bot would not lose
money over the course
of a very long game.
Interestingly, actually
a lot of the players
who came up with
this system, or a lot
of the computer
scientists, aren't
very good at poker themselves.
By their own admission,
they're not poker players.
So this is kind of a remarkable
illustration of the power
of these algorithms.
You can have people
who aren't particularly
good at poker creating
poker bots that
can beat any human arguably.
This is a remarkable
achievement.
But there is, of
course, a downside
of this in that you're assuming
that your opponent is perfect.
If you're looking for
this optimal strategy,
that's inherently defensive,
because you're assuming
that your opponent's perfect.
And you're almost giving
them too much credit.
Because if you got
a flawed opponent,
and you're coming up
with a strategy that
assumes they're perfect, you're
potentially not exploiting them
as much as you could.
And just to give an example
of these kind of flaws
that could occur, let's go
back to rock, paper, scissors.
What I'd like you
all to do is just
turn to the person
next to you and play
a couple of games of rock,
paper, scissors with them,
please.
[BACKGROUND CONVERSATIONS]
OK, thank you,
ladies and gentlemen.
OK, I can see there's
a couple at back trying
to play the best of
seven or something.
What I'd to do, can I
just have a quick show
of hands of who opened
with rock there?
OK, a fair few-- who
opened with scissors?
Quite-- and who
opened with paper?
OK, not so many
actually for paper.
So typically in these
kind of big competitions
where people play
lots of times, it's
novices that open
with rock, often men.
Scissors tends to
be the most popular
for people who play
a lot of these games.
And paper is not always
chosen so common.
Also think about what happened
between the first game
and the second game you played.
Because in one fairly
large study of rock,
paper, scissors,
what happened was
people who when the
first round typically
stick with the same
move for the second go.
So it's this old--
the military adage of
generals always fought--
always fight the last war,
especially if they won it.
So it's the idea
that if you won,
you just stick with what's safe.
People who lost,
however, will often
switch to the move that would
have beaten the one they lost.
So if they lost to
rock, they'll often
swap to paper on the next go.
So it doesn't always happen.
But in these large competitions,
these kind of patterns emerge.
So although the optimal
thing to do in rock, paper,
scissors is to behave completely
randomly, people don't.
They fall into these
predictable patterns.
And there was actually a story
a few years ago in Japan.
An electronics firm
wanted to auction off
their art collection.
And they approached
Christie's and Sotheby's
to hold the auction.
They were obviously
both keen to do it.
And so the head of
the electronics firm
decided the fairest
way to settle
it would be with a game
of rock, paper, scissors.
Now Sotheby's thought
that's perfectly random.
That's nice.
That's fine.
Christie's however,
the CEO in Japan
had a young daughter,
a 7-year-old who played
relentlessly in the playground.
So he got his daughter to
teach him a bit of rock, paper,
scissors strategy.
And they walked in sure
enough to the boredom,
Sotheby's treating it
like a random gain,
Christie's with a strategy.
Christie's walked
out the winner.
So in this kind of case,
exploiting those patterns
and those kind of predictability
and knowledge of what's
happened before can
extremely valuable.
But there are some
challenges to that.
And particularly if you
are playing computers,
one of the challenges
from a human point of view
is the limitation of our memory.
So just to illustrate this
point, what I'd like to do now
is to just all of you try and
memorise that number for me.
So I'll give you a
couple of moments
to have a quick look at it.
OK, right.
Who fancies having a go
at trying to recite it?
Any volunteers?
Yes, sir?
6, 1, 0, 2, 6, 0,
1, 0, 0, 0, 6, 8.
Very, very close, sir.
Does any one want
to have another go?
What was your name, sorry?
Gavin.
So Gavin got very close.
Any one want to try
and build on that?
Yes.
Yes?
610, 216, 1,000, 91.
So what's your name?
Steve.
Steve-- round of applause for
Steve, ladies and gentlemen.
[APPLAUSE]
Now Steve did something
quite clever there--
don't know if you spotted it.
I'll explain what he did.
So I asked you to
memorise 10 digits.
And that was actually
a bit devious of me,
because in a lot of
psychological studies,
people presented with numbers
can typically memorise
about seven and recite them.
Sorry?
12.
12 digits?
Yes.
In what?
Up there.
You said 10.
Oh, sorry.
Yeah, OK.
I do have a PhD in
maths, I assure you.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, so actually I
made it even harder.
I was crueller than I thought.
I do apologise.
And so typically
people can remember--
like a local telephone
number they can remember.
Two, they struggle with.
But what, actually, Steve did
when he recited the numbers,
he didn't recite
those individually.
He said 610, 260, 1,000, 91.
So actually what he did, he
bunched the numbers together.
He wasn't reciting ten
bits of information.
He was chunking
it into a smaller
amount, which puts it
below that threshold
that you can memorise.
And actually in other countries,
so France for instance,
if you go, their
telephone numbers
tend to be paired together.
Which actually makes it easier
to remember the numbers,
because it's much easier
for you to remember
these chunks of numbers rather
than just a single sequence.
I can actually guarantee
that all of you
will remember this number
when you go home tonight.
And that's actually if you
split it apart, and add
in some punctuation,
and then flip it around,
that's just the time
and date of this talk.
So all of you now
will know that number
and be able to recite it.
And the reason is you've gone
from 10 bits of seemingly
arbitrary information
down to one
that clearly has
some meaning to you.
And this ability to
chunk is something
that card counters employ,
because clearly memorising
a whole deck of cards
is incredibly difficult.
So what they do is they use
what's known as bucketing.
They will group into say,
low cards, medium cards,
high cards.
And then rather than having
to memorise a whole deck,
they only have these
three buckets to remember.
And what's more, it's kind
of a memoryless properties.
They don't have to
remember everything.
They can just keep the
tallies of these three values.
Of course there are
some people out there
that can memorise
vast numbers of cards.
The top memory champions can
memorise about a thousand
cards in an hour--
a thousand playing
cards in an hour.
That's remarkable.
And the way they do
that is they actually
attach characters to the cards.
This will make them
people and objects.
And they attach a story to that.
And similarly while you
will all remember this,
because you're not
remembering a number.
You're remembering an event.
You're remembering
a single thing
which is much more memorable.
And that's really
kind of how humans
can get around this idea of
the limitation of memory.
But there are some disadvantages
to learning about your opponent
and remembering
things and trying
to take advantage of them.
And that's if your
opponent's incredibly smart,
they could teach you the
wrong image of themselves.
So it's what's known as the get
taught and exploited problem.
If you're playing
poker, for instance,
your opponent could
pretend to be very passive
and pretend to be very timid.
And then once you learned
that notion of how they play,
they could actually switch their
behaviour and exploit the fact
that you've learned the
incorrect perception of them.
It's not just
poker this happens.
A couple of months
ago, you may have
seen it, a Microsoft launch of a
bot for Twitter to learn from--
I see you can see
where this is going--
to try and learn language.
And the idea was to have
conversations and improve
its ability to learn.
Twitter users unfortunately
decided to teach it
some unfortunate tricks.
What actually happened
within 24 hours,
it had to be taken down, because
it was coming out with so
many horrendous opinions.
I think that's an
example of you have
quite an intelligent algorithm.
But if it's being fed
the wrong image of what
it should be doing, it can
actually veer off track
very quickly.
And this point of
here I've talked
about poker bots who have
played billions of games
to refine their strategy.
I've talked about
these language bots.
But in many situations, these
bots aren't very complicated.
In finance, for example,
programmes are designed to be
fast.
If you're trading-- if you
want to get a trade off,
you need to do that quickly.
So having that huge
amount of complexity,
and nuance, and rationality
in your algorithm
isn't going to do the job.
You really want to strip it
down as simple as possible.
In many cases, these
high speed algorithms,
you might just have
a few lines of code.
And there's one economics
researcher I talked to put it,
when you're at
ten lines of code,
you're not even at insect
level intelligence.
You've got no rationality
and no nuance in there.
You're just trying
to execute the trades
as quickly as possible.
In some situations this means
that you can run into trouble.
There's a case
recently in Norway,
where two traders had
noticed that a US stock
broker had an algorithm that was
feeding trades at the market.
And the algorithm
would always react
to a trade in the same way.
In other words, if
you traded with it,
it would change its
price by the same amount
no matter how big
that trade was.
So what these
people in Norway did
was teach the
algorithm what to do.
So it made lots
of little trades.
So it would move its price
up and then make a big trade
and profit from the difference.
Now this ended up in court.
These two traders were charged
with market manipulation
and handed suspended sentences.
But then there's a
Robin Hood reputation
in the media for them in Norway.
And it went to appeal.
And their appeal
lawyer made the point
of if they had been trading
against a stupid human who
was doing this, that
wouldn't be a problem.
The issue is that
they were trading
at a stupid algorithm
presumably created
by a human that hadn't been
thinking what they were doing.
And how should
this be different?
How should the notion of
skill and responsibility
be different because
as a kind of one step
away for the algorithm?
And actually this
argument held in court.
And in this situation,
they were actually--
this sentence was revoked.
And this isn't the
first it's instance
a very simple algorithm
would fall into trouble.
A similar point actually--
a US stock broker was
introducing a new algorithm
to feed orders into the market.
So you have a lot of
orders from clients
coming into the stock broker.
And it would want
to feed them in.
They had eight
servers doing this.
What they had is a counter
actually to keep track,
because obviously if you got
lots of orders coming in,
and you're sending
them out to the market,
you want to keep track of
how many you've completed.
You don't want to
accidentally make too many.
And they had one of these
counts at each server.
And then they updated
their software.
But by all accounts, they
didn't add the counter
to the eighth server.
So there are seven servers that
knew what they were doing--
the eighth one that was
kind of doing its own thing.
And when this went
live, what happened
was the seven were
behaving as they should.
The eighth just peppered the
market with high speed trades.
And actually by the
time they worked out
what was happening
and shut it down,
in 45 minutes it had
lost about $450 million.
So that's a $170,000 a second
for this runaway algorithm,
because it was acting
so fast and so much
beyond what humans
could control.
And you might call
that bad luck.
You might call that
error in skill.
And I think those cases around
these kind of games and chance
events are developing actually.
In the US in recent
years, there's
been a big crackdown on
poker, particularly online.
And as well in 2012,
there was a crackdown
on New York on poker
rooms on a gentleman who
was running a poker room
that was taken to court
and charged with operating
a gambling operation.
Now many casino games in federal
law are defined as gambling.
But poker isn't one of them.
So actually whether
it was gambling or not
was up for debate.
And in federal law, gambling
is defined as anything that
is predominantly due to chance.
So any game that's predominantly
the result of chance
is defined as gambling.
So what happened is this
entire legal case rested on
is poker a game of chance
or a game of skill.
And they got economists
coming in-- mathematicians.
And they made the point that
on a single game of poker,
of course there's
an element of luck,
because you got this deal.
But then equally in
baseball, if someone's
pitching a single
ball, there's going
to be an element
of chance involved.
But over the course
of a poker game,
typically the more
skillful players won.
And this was the first time
actually that a US court
had ruled on whether
poker is a game of chance
or a game of skill.
And they ruled that it
was a game of skill.
There's a footnote
to this story.
The following year when it went
to the State Appeals Court.
Now in New York
state law, gambling
is defined as anything that has
a material element of chance.
So if you think about this, this
is a much narrower definition
of gambling.
It's not predominantly chance.
It's anything with
a material element,
which clearly poker does have.
And under this condition
it's defined as gambling.
And this debate is ongoing.
If you look fancy sports
in the US and a lot
of these systems where--
do we have something
that's luck.
Do we have something
that's skill?
Where do we-- do we
actually define these things
as gambling?
I think there's
often a temptation
in fact with these situations
to put things in boxes.
We like to say there's
a box with luck,
and there's a box with skill.
I think typically if
we're good at something,
it goes in the box on the right.
If we're bad at something, it
goes in the box on the left.
And that's really tempting.
But I don't think it's a
realistic notion necessarily.
I think particularly
through the history
of how people have tackled
games like roulette
and with lotteries is
much more of a spectrum.
And actually games
that we might think
are the archetype of luck,
things like roulette,
actually if you have
a skillful approach
you can tame that chance.
And you can convert it into
some element of a game of skill.
And even games
that we might think
are incredibly, almost
solely the work of skill,
games like chess can have
surprising results of chance.
In the '90s, famously, IBM's
Deep Blue chess computer
played Gary Kasparov.
And during the match in
one of the early games,
there was a situation
where Deep Blue made
a move that was so unexpected
and almost so subtle
that it threw
Kasparov off a bit--
all accounts
convinced him that he
was playing something
that was just simply
beyond what he was--
ever seen before-- just
something completely
beyond his capability.
It turned out actually
that what happened
there is Deep Blue had run into
a situation where it couldn't
identify the best move.
And in that
situation it had been
programmed to pick randomly.
So this set of games that
is one of the landmarks
in artificial intelligence
over humans in a game
that is thought
to be purely skill
was actually really shaped
by this chance event.
And I think these kind of
illustrations show why gambling
and why these games of
chance are so important.
Because really
whatever your views
are of casinos and
bookmakers, gambling
is an inherent part of life.
Betting is an inherent
part of what we do,
whether it's in health in
prediction on this side--
whether it's in business--
whether in finance.
We have to make decisions
with hidden information.
We have to deal
with uncertainty.
We have to balance the
risks against the rewards.
I think that's why historically
so many researchers have
been interested in gambling
and continue to do so.
Because really if you want to
understand luck, and decision
making, and risk, then
arguably there's no way better
to start than with a bet.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
What your view of where
investing in the stock market
might fall between
luck and skill,
should I pay somebody a
2% fee for their skill
at investing my money?
Or should I just rely
on buying the market?